That's why you have to
prepare.  Ever since I was little, I've tasted ingredients from all over the country.Of
course, I'll share that knowledge with you about Hokkaido as well
.
I'm going to hit it hard, but I won't allow any whining I can
follow you
[music] It
's great Hello Mita-san Potatoes
You can't talk about Hokkaido food without this.
All kinds of varieties are
planted.To start with, let's have all the characteristics in mind
.
Everyone,
what a great momentum, isn't it? Azami Nakiri wouldn't have thought that things were going to turn out like this.
We and you are both against Central's methods,
aren't you?  I'm doing it, and I'm going to
get a snow opening,
but I don't know if this will really help the exam, and what the
school will do
.
Just like you've been doing until now Hey,
don't open a hole These people should be able to do that